are you all today good excellent I'm
good - I'm really happy to be here happy
to be in London real quick introduction
my name is Edward Thompson I'm a product
manager at github I work on github
actions and I was hoping to tell you a
little bit about what that is in case
you hadn't heard of it show you what you
can do to enable your repositories to
either do continuous integration sort of
build test and deploy or to do some more
exotic things that are outside the realm
of a traditional CI CD system and sort
of run some automation within your
repository so if I look back you know if
I just kind of rewind a little bit
the really impressive thing about being
at github is that it is in many ways the
home of software development right and I
don't I'm not trying to you know be too
too grand about that because a lot of
people use different platforms for
hosting their software right you not
everybody uses github and that's totally
understandable but everybody uses
something that at some point was
developed on github right because it's
the open source community most open
source projects are on github and most
of us are now using open source within
our prod products our projects software
that we're building so at some point we
interact with github either directly
whether we host our software there or
indirectly because we end up using some
dependency that ends up there and so one
of the interesting things about working
at github is trying to understand how
y'all use it and how we can make your
lives easier again whether you're using
it directly or indirectly and one of the
things that one of the problems that we
have as hovers as people who are you
know working on github itself is that we
have software engineers as our customers
and that can be challenging because
y'all like to build stuff and so when we
you know put github out there and give
it to you a lot of you look at it and
say cool that's great but I want to do
this instead or this is a great starting
place for me I want to take it and
extend it and I think that's great you
know I think that we need to let you do
that and and so one of the things that
we've been doing over the last couple
years is trying to find ways to serve
you in that regard
so the first thing that we did was we
created these things called github apps
the idea of a github app is that it is a
sort of well defined you know a little
bit of code that you can take and extend
right you're given web hooks so every
time anything happens on github we fire
web hooks that you can subscribe to
whether that's creating an issue or
opening a pull request that could be
creating a new release or just tagging
something every time you do anything on
github we will fire these web hooks and
you can listen to them and then you can
do your own thing
you can talk back to it with our API and
that's a github app and I think that was
a great start right the problem here is
that you need to bring your own
infrastructure right so github will fire
you an issue comment but you have to
have a server listening whether that's
you know something in your data center
something in a cloud maybe if it's a
server list if you don't have like you
know super hard core requirements maybe
it's a server under a desk right we all
know how well that works out and so the
problem is that that you're hosting your
own infrastructure and that's fine for
some things but it's not really
necessary for everything right because
when you are hosting your own
infrastructure that starts getting
expensive whether that's an actual cost
like you are paying for a server or a
fixed cost like or you know sort more
abstract cost rather
that server under the desk that's gonna
get kicked over and turned off and all
of a sudden your infrastructure fails
and you don't even know why because you
have this dependency so we rewound a
little bit and said well maybe we can
fix the infrastructure problem and that
was sort of the genesis of github
actions the idea is that instead of
making you bring your own infra to the
party will host it for you we have
servers in our data center we have s RDS
that manage them you know and an ops
team that's on call we can take care of
that burden for you and so the idea of
github actions is we will still let you
listen to the same events to those same
web hooks so every time somebody creates
an issue every time somebody opens a
pull request whatever will fire these
events but will fire them into one of
our own pieces of infrastructure so now
you can define this and respond to it
even and you can create this in scripted
but we'll take care of it and that was
the idea of github actions the idea is
that you know instead of making you
bring your own app we'll we'll host it
for you so we launched this a little
over a year ago in beta the idea was I
think still a great idea
what we did was we gave you a docker
container and let you you know run some
things in containers on our Linux
servers and they weren't very powerful
but that's ok because you know when you
when you're responding to a new issue
doesn't need to be powerful and so we're
really excited about the things that
people would build and we put it in beta
and we got a response that everybody
hated it right the idea was really good
but the thing that people want to do you
know as soon as you give this to them
they're like great I can do something
when somebody opens an issue I can do
something when somebody opens a pull
request and with that thing I want to do
when somebody opens a pull request is
run a CI build and we were just not
geared up for that you know if you had a
node app that ran on Linux didn't
require a lot of you know CPU to build
probably fine worked okay if you have an
iOS app
that needs a Mac to build that's not
gonna work like not at all right so we
really quickly realized that we had a
good idea but the execution wasn't quite
there so we sort of went back retooled
and came out with an update and in that
update we basically give you virtual
machines to run on instead of requiring
you to run inside a docker container so
now you can run github actions in either
a Linux virtual machine or a Windows
virtual machine in case you're I don't
know building dotnet framework or a Mac
in case you are building an iOS app you
can still run things in docker
containers if you want you can create
docker containers you can compose docker
containers you know we can we can still
support all of that sort of docker magic
that we had but now we can do it in
different places as well so we're no
longer tying you to Linux and this was
what we released actually just a few
months ago into GA so this is now
generally available it is ready to go
for all your workloads whether that's
responding to an issue you know doing
something when somebody creates a
release or a tag or actually doing
continuous integration and deployment so
we're really excited about that
let me actually
there we go see if this is gonna work
let's actually take a look at what that
looks like there we go so here I have a
super simple node application it's uh
it's a it's got a back-end that has a
REST API that you can do that you can
call for doing arithmetic simple
arithmetic 1 plus 1 2 plus 2 so if you
ever need you know simple arithmetic as
a service I've got you covered
it's also got a little front end right
here kind of looks like the sort of
pocket calculator that you might have
had if you're super old like me this is
what we carry in our pockets before we
had iPhones right if you're my age you
probably remember so 4 plus 4 equals 8
cool does this job what I want to do
here is I want to open source this and I
want to be able to take contributions
from the community and when I do that
what I really want is to make sure that
those contributions are good right I
want to do a continuous integration
build I want to run my tests I hope that
this isn't like you know
earth-shattering I hope that everybody
seen CII and is familiar with it
so I'm not gonna you know belabor this
too much so I do want but I do want to
show what it looks like in the context
of github actions so if you have a
github repository
you might notice you might have noticed
that now you have this actions tab up
top that's sort of the gateway to
getting started with github actions if
you haven't already it's also where
we'll go and look at our workflow runs
so I'm going to click that tab and this
is how I set up a new CI CD build the
first thing that we do is we scan your
repository we use a tool called linguist
to look at what is in your repository if
you've ever clicked on this button right
here this bar rather that's the same
thing that we use here we we actually
analyze your repository to find out what
kind of code you have in it in this case
I have JavaScript so when I go to the
actions tab and I have this sort of get
started workflow it uses that same
analysis and it knows that I have a
JavaScript repository so it offers me
some JavaScript workflows that I can use
and this one right here
no das build and test a node.js project
I'm gonna choose that one just click
setup and I've got Gamal so github
actions is all defined by Emily Yunel is
like the the language of DevOps at this
point right whether you love it or you
don't
so much love it it is in fact what
everybody uses and is what github
actions uses as well so this is the ml
that defines my workflow so that so this
will run in this case every time
somebody pushes into my my repository
I'm gonna go ahead and commit this
workflow so that it'll actually queue a
build while I sort of look at what that
yam will actually looks like right so
because I did do a push into my
repository if I hit reload it should
have queued a should queue a build there
we go
so that's actually running right now so
while that runs let me actually just
unpack what what is in this Yambol right
I'm gonna go ahead and click Edit there
we go
so my workflow has a name very
straightforward
it's also got this clause right here on
rank it now it says on push this is
actually how we how you trigger things
right so just like we used to fire web
hooks that you can listen to that's the
same concept so I'm listening for push
events I could listen for pull requests
events I could listen for issue events
and I can even type it more narrowly
right so let me say this so for those of
you who groan I did hear a groan when I
said that we use Hamel this is what
makes UML bearable in my mind we've
actually got autocomplete we've got
syntax highlighting so you've got red
squigglies right here because right now
I have on with no value it says the
value cannot be no
and it is actually suggesting me the
things that I can do so I can run on
push I can run on pull request can run
when a deployment starts I can run on
golem
that's a beard one if anybody's ever dug
into the github API golem is actually
the light was the internal ashamed for
our wiki so all of our web hooks are
still called golem for the wiki so I can
run every time a wiki gets updated so
I've got a real wide range of things I
can do it's not just a CI CD platform
but in this case I'm gonna keep it on
push okay and then what happens is I'll
to find some jobs jobs will run in
parallel on different machines I just
want to have one job and that's my build
job it's gonna run on Ubuntu latest
again we have Linux machines we have
Windows machines for you that we host
and we have Mac's we actually have to go
and rack max because you can't
virtualize it that's a that's an apple
requirement so we've got a lot of trash
cans taking up a lot of space in racks
because they're not really designed to
go in that way really not space
efficient
protip don't ever run a data center full
of max then we've got actually my
favorite part of github actions and
that's our matrix support a matrix lets
you really easily define a piece of
workflow and then repeat it so I can
define steps that I want to run and then
I can define a matrix that defines that
will let me expand those steps out into
in this case three different runs so
what I want to do is I want to run my
workflow on node 8 node 10 and no 12
just to make sure that it's compatible
across all of them so I can define a
matrix and this is just a key value
mapping this is like super simple
variable substitution there's like
nothing advanced going on here
so what I'm doing is I'm setting a a key
called node version and when my workflow
runs it will run my steps with that key
set to 880 X and then it will run it
again with
key set to ten dot X and it will run it
again with that key set to twelve dot X
and in my steps I can actually use that
variable substitution and that looks
like that so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna run this action called setup node
and it'll run with eight ten and twelve
so basically that just puts the sets up
the environment for node and puts it in
the path and those sorts of things and
then once that's set up at the
particular version I'm gonna npm install
to get my dependencies I'm gonna NPM run
build and then I'm gonna NPM test so
with this and this is just the sample
workload and this is just out of the box
I just clicked go you know it detected
that I had a node.js application and
this is what it gives me so when that
runs and that was running while I was
explaining that to you what I actually
get is one run with three different
workflows that variable expansion in the
matrix ran on eight ten and twelve and I
can click in there and see what it
actually did so I can expand these steps
out if npm install' put in my defendants
ease and p.m. run build javascript
nothing to do here but that's obviously
useful if you've got typescript instead
or you know some sort of compilation
script in a build script and then
finally NPM test and in this case it
went through and you know it makes sure
that it knows how to add two numbers so
again not the most impressive athlete in
the world but you know even when you're
even when you're doing simple math
that's good to have unit tests because
that stuff can break right
how can it break you ask well JavaScript
you can break anything that's my
favorite part of JavaScript so like I
said I wanted to open source this I want
to allow contributions and so what can
happen is let's say somebody comes along
they take a look at this app they open
up arithmetic controller this is the
back end they scroll down and they say
oh okay
well this is obviously the mapping of
how arithmetic works in this but
something looks weird right it ad looks
kind of weird I don't I don't know
what's going on here if I we're not a
JavaScript expert and I am NOT a
JavaScript expert I would look at that
and say that looks weird
subtract looks and totally normal a
minus B that's how you subtract numbers
multiply is fine a times B divided you
know it all checks out it's just ad is
really plus a plus plus B I bet we can
simplify that right so I'm gonna click
Edit I can edit it right in the web come
down here just make it a plus B right
that's how you add two numbers surely
I'll scroll down here give it a nice
title open a pull request
there we go and once I click create pull
request now what happens is we will
actually queue a workflow build with
github actions right and this isn't
anything groundbreaking here right this
this would happen if you used at your
pipelines this would happen if you use
Travis but of course it also runs when
you use github actions and I can click
into one of my runs Oh in fact oh geez
they've all failed oh wow what's going
on here let's look at let's open that
one up expand that out and we can scroll
through our Oh huh well let's zoom in so
this is actually the way that unit tests
are reported in in this framework like a
diff sort of get diff sort of result
what we expected was that adding the
numbers 21 and 21 would give us 42 what
it actually did was give us two one two
one
wolf JavaScript so what happened is when
I had plus a plus plus B JavaScript was
coercing my stringy things into numbers
right without that plus a or without
that a plus B is string concatenation so
21 plus 21 gives us two one two one ouch
so that's why you have unit tests even
when things seem really really simple so
we know whoops we know that this is not
a good pull request so as a maintainer I
would not accept it I would you know
come up with a nice way to to do that
hopefully but this protects us from
getting code into our master branch that
that isn't good you can turn on branch
protections at this point to like really
enforce it
I don't know about y'all I used to have
a coworker he would write a bunch of
code check it in get in his car and
drive home without having actually built
or tested it and so this was many many
years ago before
see ICD was commonplace and so this is
you know I think of him every time I I
accidently you know break something in a
pull request and it doesn't even compile
so which happens there's no shame in
that but we need to keep it out of our
master branch that needs to stay healthy
so that is you know the value prop of of
CI and I hope you all are doing it
already but github actions makes it
quite a bit easier if you're on the
github platform to get started so like I
said when we introduced github actions
the goal was repository automation at
first we didn't have CI CD in mind you
know we could have built this back then
even on those docker containers things
that are harder to build or Net
Applications because you might run a
want to run that on Windows I like to
run my CI a the same place I'm gonna
deploy it if you run your CI on Linux
deploy to Windows or vice versa
you never know what kind of weird
problems you might have you know case
sensitivity is different the legal file
names that you can actually have are
different so I think it's important to
run CI at the same place you do your
deployment so I've got a dotnet app and
if I were deploying it to a Windows
platform I could do that so this is this
is a dotnet core app it's actually a a
blazer app I think that's what they call
it today not razor pages it's now blazer
again if you don't know what blazer is
you should actually be in the room next
door because that's being explained so
I'm gonna trust you all know what blazer
is I won't go too much into depth but
this is you know just a dotnet hello
world app it's super duper
over-engineered because I have a
shameful secret and that is that I used
to be a Java developer so it is you know
like it extremely abstracted it's got
you know various factories to build
things and I think that's fine right
because like I said Java but what I want
to do is I want to build it so if I go
to the
actions tab just like sorry the actions
tab there we go
just like before when when it scanned my
JavaScript project this is going to
decide that I have a dotnet application
which I do and suggest a network flow
for me so I'm going to go ahead and
click setup it's very straightforward
you can look at it in this case I want
to make two changes the first thing I
want to do I don't want to run on a bun
to anymore because if I want to deploy
to Windows I want to do my build on
Windows so I'm going to change that to
Windows latest that will give me our
newest version of Windows that we have
in our data centers and the other thing
I want to do is run on dotnet version
3.0 dot 100 that is I think that's the
GA for dotnet core 3 I forget I forget
exactly but that's like the minimum
version for blazer I think I seem to
have that in my head let's give it a try
it might not work I'm gonna go ahead and
commit this and when I do it's going to
again just like before kick off a github
actions workflow run so I'll click into
there click reload click reload again
there we go and it's actually started my
run so I can click in there and my
favorite thing of actions is matrixes
matrices my second favorite thing is
actually being able to watch the run
live so you can see it's doing our git
clone it's setting up dotnet dotnet core
in this case again version 3.0 point 100
it's actually installing it right now so
it turns out I got that version number
right that's great and then it's gonna
do my dotnet core build if I had unit
tests it would actually run them woops
that's that one's on me so the cool
thing about this is that it isn't
actually running on a a Windows server
so again I think that your deployment
target and your CI platform should match
I think that's a really powerful reason
that we brought in Windows machines
there we go it's actually doing my
dotnet build three point one point 101 I
was close I was off by one but it
figured it out see I still remember how
to write software even though I'm a
product manager I can still write
software
I have off-by-one errors and still so
again we have Linux we have Windows we
also have apples like I said we've
racked a bunch of apple machines into
our data center so that you can do your
iOS builds and then you know I don't
know deploy data to the App Store or if
you're you know whatever the reason you
might want to deploy to using a Mac is
so here I've got a game that I've
written in Swift it's a it's a
concentration game or I don't know what
you call it in the in the UK is it still
concentration the idea is that you have
tiles that you need to match and sorry I
don't expect you to read this but I do
have again tests for that so you can see
exactly how it goes I there we go so
like I said I'm a product manager not a
software engineer anymore and so I
needed to figure out how to test if you
could win the game so I've reinforced it
I'm sure there's better ways to do this
but this is the product managers
approach to problem solving so one of
the things that I want to make sure that
I'm able to do is actually you know just
like before run a build and run unit
tests so that if somebody is
contributing or if I'm working you know
late at night that I can't contribute or
I can't push something in a master that
breaks the build so the cool thing about
having physical max in our data center
is that you can actually run all of this
it's got the iPhone the iOS simulators
installed so you can actually run all of
the UI tests with in github actions so
if I pop back to there we go so if I pop
back here and go to the actions tab it
will offer me up a Swift workflow which
is indeed exactly what I'm running this
time it's instead of running on Ubuntu
latest or Windows latest I'm gonna run
on Mac OS latest I'm gonna change my
workflow just a little bit I got this
crazy Xcode command that will actually
run the run the iOS simulator and so I
want to change this so I'm gonna change
run there we go that's very very long so
the run command in github actions is
basically just something that will run
in a shell in this case bash let me go
ahead and start my commitment
there we go and again when I do since I
since my trigger is on push and by
committing this file so the the moral
equivalent of push is something got
merged into my repository somebody ran
get push on the command line or somebody
use the web and edited directly and
master don't do the last one please
that's that's not a super good practice
but you know I'm gonna I'm gonna do it
here for the sake of demonstration so
that means this workflow is now running
if I go into it I can open this up I can
expand this tab it hasn't quite started
yet there we go and we can see that it's
actually gonna do my compilation and
then it's actually gonna start running
my unit tests even my UI tests so I can
scroll down and it's starting my UI
tests right now so it's simulating an
iPhone 11 running iOS thirteen point two
in fact thirteen point two point two
there we go and it's actually doing the
test and it so in a second it will
actually start debugging output and my
unit test sphere will tap through well
virtually tap through every tile in that
game to make sure that it is in fact
winnable and so you'll actually see that
output at some point saying that it's
actually doing the taps there we go so
it's starting up tapping each button in
time so that's really cool you can use
github actions to actually make sure
that your UI works and this is true
doesn't have to be an iOS app with Swift
you could do this with selenium or any
sort of browser-based tests that you
have you can run those right in our
harness as well so that is CI in a
nutshell so we're doing our build we're
doing our test now
often we would want to do a deployment
so I want to come back to my calculator
application and what I want to do is
deploy it to a cloud provider so if I
click on the actions tab I've got my
workflow runs including my broken pull
request but I want to click create a new
workflow instead of a CI workflow I want
to do a deploy workflow and so we've
actually partnered with some of the
clouds too to bring starter workflows
right into our getting started
experience so you can deploy to Amazon
you can deploy to Azure you can deploy
to Google really easily in this case I'm
I'm actually an azure user I used to
work at Microsoft so I'm very familiar
with a sure that's what I want to use so
I'm gonna go ahead and click to set up
this workflow and what this will do is
it will go ahead and and get started and
create a build a node application and
deploy it to as your web app and so most
of the things that we've done so far
we've just been running commands on the
command line this one is a little bit
different this last step the deploy step
instead of a run it's a uses and it says
uses as your web apps deploy at v1 so
this is using an action so we can have
workflows that are just running shell
scripts running command line steps or we
can have workflows that use actions so
an action is just a reasonable piece of
code that you build and you put in a git
repository on github to share with
others and in this case the azure team
has built this web Maps deploy action
and what it does is like the name
suggests it deploys a web app to Azure
it needs a little bit of configuration
right here and so it's you know you just
give it an azure published profile in
your secrets and you're basically good
to go what is a secret if we go into our
repository settings we can go to secrets
and we can add basically variables
we'll get expanded by the workflow and
we'll hide them from you no we won't put
these in the logs we won't display them
within the UI they are in fact intended
to stay secret and I set one up that's
my Asher publish profile I did this
ahead of time so that I didn't have to
like copy and paste it in because I'm
sure you all are very trustworthy but
you know the folks watching at home
might take my publish profile and start
crypto mining I don't have that kind of
money so I'm just gonna gonna hide it so
I've already configured that as a secret
and then I'm gonna go again to my
actions tab go back to the new workflow
select the azure again and I've actually
made a few changes let's find my sorry
there we go hiding back here I want to
actually use a slightly different
version there we go because I've already
gone ahead and set up an app it's got
it's called calc yes I didn't actually
setup the secret that they that the
starter workflow did basically it just
puts it in as a secret I don't need that
secret nobody's gonna nobody needs to
tell you no I don't need hidden the fact
that my app is named calc J s and then
again I'm gonna use that published
profile and so the other thing that I've
changed is that I've changed the trigger
so this is not in the default the
default runs on push what I want to do
is run on release and so I'm gonna go
ahead and check this in and then I'll
show you what that looks like right so I
just check this in so my default my CI
workflow is now running this is the one
that runs on push it runs my building it
runs my test what's not running is my
deploy workflow because I change the
trigger I only want to deploy once I
feel good about my project once I've you
know done some manual testing and what
the way I want to do that is by going
through the new release process on
github so I'm gonna click create new
release there we go we'll call it v1 and
we'll click publish
so if I go back and look at my workflow
you Hammel the azure deploy workflow
again I've changed this trigger so we
were looking at on push before now I'm
running on release and releases a broad
category of actions on github I only
want to run when a release is created so
if I just left this blank I would run on
all release types so if somebody deletes
a release I would run my deployment
workflow that's no good right
you're probably deleting a release
because it was bad you don't want to
publish it I only want to release to
production when I've actually created a
new release and so I just did that so if
I go over to my actions tab I should see
that running indeed I do
there's my deploy to a sure workflow and
in fact it claims to have succeeded what
I didn't do was change any code so you I
I can't prove that let's actually make a
little change and then we will do
another deploy so if I go into my public
file folder rather this is where my
static components go I've got a I've got
a new background I want to use and I
don't know if you all know this you can
just drag and drop right into github so
I can drag and drop a new file in I can
commit it this is great for things like
wikis this is maybe not so great for
your actual source code you know and
whoops let me again go back into public
and I'm going to change my CSS I'm gonna
change the background color to match the
new image whoops I click the pin I can
edit it right in the browser 6/8 1 B 1 B
there we go
and I'll go ahead and check that in and
then I'll tag a new release and it will
do a whole new deploy
there we go call it v2
go ahead and kick that off great so that
actually did do a new deploy it also
kicked off the CI as well because I did
a push while that's running and it will
take a minute to run and do the deploy
restart the web app etc takes just a
minute let me actually show a different
deployment type while that's that's
going on one of the other things that
we've done at github is we have there we
go
great we have a new another new product
within github we also released it to
general availability in November at
github universe and that's called github
packages and basically github can act as
a private package registry or you know
or a public package registry whichever
you prefer the idea being that like
maybe if you're producing nougat
packages like I maintain an open-source
library for.net and so I build nougat
packages and I publish them to nougat
org so that you all can download them so
that you can just type nougat install or
a.net install whatever my package right
and I'll pull it down to him to get org
but I only want to put releases there I
don't want to put you know pre-release
hacky things that I want to test so what
I can do is I can push my final releases
to nougat org I can push my interim
NuGet packages my testing nougat
packages up to github packages and that
way people who want to test my you know
the very latest cutting-edge version of
my open-source library they can point
their nougat registry to to get hub
packages and get the very latest newest
version we can collaborate on that we
can
work on it test it I can get feedback
and then once it's actually released
I'll publish that up - nuketown org and
so github packages will host NPM it'll
host Ruby maven Gradle docker nougat etc
and so this is a really cool way to you
know to work with that sort of workflow
the the thing that I like most about it
though is that it actually integrates
really well with github actions there we
go
and so I can do a deploy to Azure just
like that and if I hit reload this now
should be read well the backgrounds read
meant to update the image - but alas
that was my bad instead of just
deploying to Azure though now I can also
create a deployment out of this project
- to github packages so if we if we look
here one of the things I have in here is
a docker file so when I am deploying
this you know I could do a normal web
app deploy like we did or I could build
a docker container and deploy that
container to a container registry and
then ultimately to a web app in the
cloud or in my data center etc so this
is really straightforward all we do is
run NPM and then bundle it up into a
docker container but one of the things
that I like to do is if I'm gonna do a
docker deploy I'm gonna do a container
deploy to the cloud if that's the way I
release my application I want to be able
to test that docker container exactly as
it's going to be deployed locally and so
one of the things that I can now do is
run a github action workflow that will
create a docker file and then publish
that to github packages then I can
download it test it make sure it works
before I actually deploy it to
production and so if I go back to my
actions tab I want to create yet another
workflow so we'll click new workflow
there and again it detects that I'm John
script repository but I can also scroll
down and look at all these other starter
work clothes one of them is create a
docker image great and the default is
super simple it just runs docker build
and gives it a tag it tags it with the
current date so that's a that's a
reasonable version number this is if
you're not familiar with this syntax
this will just give you instead of the
date in text it will give you the number
of seconds since the UNIX epoch January
1 1970 so it's just a monotonically
increasing number makes a great version
number so this works really quite well
but what I want to actually do is take
it a step farther and publish this to
github packages so I'm going to go ahead
and just snag this workflow here and I'm
going to I'm going to paste it in this
also runs on release so I'm going to
create a new release so I can kick it
off because it'll take a second and then
I'll explain what we're actually doing
so go back to the releases tab if I
create the three now we've got two
workflows that run on release creation
we've got the one that deploys to Azure
and we've got this new one that will
deploy to the will create a docker
container in and put it in github
packages so let's go back and look at
what it's actually doing there we go so
again we're running on release we're
gonna do it on Ubuntu we're gonna use
node 12 and then we are going to the
first thing we do is we run docker login
so we actually need to login to our
package registry in this case github
packages and we'll login with this
password that is the github token secret
now if we if we remember when we looked
at secrets before what we didn't we saw
the azure publish profile but we didn't
see this github token so this is
actually something that github
it's in your workflow run automatically
it is a token that you can use to access
your repository and if you are running
you know as a on a release or running a
CI build it actually has write access to
your repository if you're running a pull
request from a fork it does not write we
so we want to keep that secure so that
nobody can just come in and start
running you know you're running things
that can write to your repository so
Forks don't get a writable version of
this token but you do and so you can use
it to do things like publish to github
packages so it's basically already set
up for you all you need to do is log in
and then we'll build our docker
container and then we'll push it so
docker push to docker package github
calm that is github packages and we'll
give it the name of our repository and
we'll call it app and we will give it a
version and again that's the same
version that we used before which is
that the number of second since January
1 1970 so if I go over to the actions
tab I should see that this has run
actually it failed what did I do wrong
the magic of live demos ah turns out I
need a different name I've already got a
package named app so let's let's go
ahead and give it another name and start
a new workflow run so instead of app
we'll call it app to start that commit
and go ahead and create a new release
and let it run one more time okay and
we'll come back we'll give it a minute
we'll let it run and we'll we'll come
back to that one of the other things
while that's running one of the other
things that I love about github actions
in its integration with other github
products is our integration with the new
security tools that github has been
producing we have a tool called
dependable we that came in through an
acquisition this was a really cool tool
that we really loved and so we wanted it
to be part of github and so now it is
the idea of dependable is that it will
look at your dependencies the open
source projects that you rely on within
your own software projects and depend
upon can analyze what you're using so
most of us are using open source
projects sometimes those open source
projects have security vulnerabilities
and these are widely published you know
they're white they're announced so that
you know that you can upgrade them
except most of us aren't like reading
the mailing lists for the software
projects that we use and even if we were
you know you could have some transitive
dependency right like you could depend
on a project that depends on a project
that depends on a project that has a
security vulnerability and you don't
even know it obviously right so the idea
behind dependable is that it does know
it all it has to do is look at your
project see what you're using and look
at this database of security
vulnerabilities because there is a
common database because they all
go get what are called sea V's CVE is I
think it stands for common vulnerability
and exposure it's a security bug so you
can easily match the tools that you're
using to this database to know whether
you are vulnerable and attackers do this
too if you're an American like I am you
have to deal with credit bureaus and
credit reporting agencies and they
basically have all of your information
about your social security number and
the loans that you have how much money
you have this is bad stuff to get out
and they also haven't have websites
websites sometimes have vulnerabilities
and in fact one of them did I'm not
gonna name names but one of them had a
website with a security vulnerability
and you know an attacker just like
blasted the internet looking at the
headers that are returned from websites
and saw that one of them was vulnerable
to this app like the header said hey
here's the software that I'm using and
it was vulnerable so they just you know
found a vulnerability to lat would get
them into this website got in and from
there they had a foothold into the
network eventually got into a production
database of credit card or credit
information and that's why like to this
day I still get random people trying to
steal my identity it's great it's great
fun had they used a tool like dependable
there are a lot of there are a lot of
great tools that do this but depend
about is built into github so it can
actually just tell you exactly when this
happens so I would like to say that I
planned this but in fact this happened
organically I built this repository a
while ago and one day this message
popped up telling me that I had a
security vulnerability so github
actually scanned my repository and this
is an opt-in sort of thing right this
this isn't something that you have to do
and it told me this it also only shows
the owner this right only the only the
owner can see this message so it's not
like anybody browsing your repository
on github this will be super obvious to
them so the cool thing about dependable
is that not only does it know that I
have a security vulnerability it also
knows how to fix it
so if I click view Security Alert it
will take me there
the problem is lo - if you've been
hacking a lot of JavaScript you might
have seen this warning before but if I
click in I can scroll through and it'll
tell me exactly what to do right what I
need to do is to upgrade lo - to version
4.17 12 or later and it'll tell me
exactly how to do that this is the this
is the line that I need to change great
so I can go and make that change
the cool thing again about depend bots
is that since it knows that it can
actually do this for me so if I pop over
to holder requests it actually has so
dependable has now opened a pull request
for me so this is an automated pull
request that fixes that security
vulnerability depend a bot has has done
that if I look at the files changed it
did exactly what it told me to do there
we go
it removed for version and 4.17 dot 11
that's the vulnerable version it's added
version there we go for doubt 17.15
that's the newest version ok well that's
that's helpful but since we have github
actions running on this project we also
know that this version update was good
you know assuming we have good unit
tests and I feel good about my unit
tests we now know that that that version
update the depend about did for us
worked reliably so I have a very high
confidence that I can just click merge
pull request and fix this security
vulnerability so between the time that
the vulnerability happened
I've gotten an alert in my email I'm
every time I go to the repository I see
this alert and I've got a pull request
that fixes it and I know that it fixes
it the right way because I have my
builds and my tests passing so
I am really really excited about that in
particular I think that's my what did I
say first that's my third favorite part
of github actions is how it integrates
with the other tools and other products
that are on github and like I said it
does integrate with github packages
let's make sure that let's see why that
one failed so I changed it in one place
and not the other so if we go back and
look at my container workflow I changed
the name of the docker container that I
was producing it was I originally called
an app I had to change it to app 2
because I already had a container a
package called app cuz I ran this
earlier getting set up but I forgot to
change it in the second line that does
the push and it's my bad I need to
create a variable I'm gonna go ahead and
kick off another build just so that it
actually works before I finish up so one
more release we'll call it v5 kick that
off and while that's running I want to
say one thing about actions themselves
right so we've talked about workflows
we've created a lot of workflows and one
of those workloads used in action it was
the deploy to Azure action and I kind of
mentioned that it was sort of this
reusable component that you can publish
and that multiple workflows whether it's
whether they're yours or you can put
them make them publicly available can
then use that action and so I want to
look a little bit more at what that
looks like so an action is a JavaScript
application or typescript if you prefer
that will run in the context of a github
actions
workflow so we saw one which was the
deploy to Azure but that is by no means
the only one if we go to the so from
that if we go to the github marketplace
you can actually see a number of actions
that people have created and made
available so here's one this one will
help you build and publish a Jekyll site
to get hub pages scroll down a little
bit
various there we go this one will run
roubo cop so if you're a ruby developer
Robocop is the lentor for ruby it's a
style checker it's it's really handy we
use it a github all the time and in fact
one of my co-workers has created this
action to help with that so all you need
to do is say uses what's it called ruby
comp action and grubo cop checks all you
have to do is say uses Robocop checks
and it will in fact then run roubo cop
and the cool thing here is that it will
actually put these check failures right
in line so it'll tell you exactly what
the problem was
this is a poorly named method it's using
camelcase this person has opted in to
snake case as their requirements for
their project and so it will actually
just highlight the line and so this will
actually drop in an annotation right
within github comm so you can see
exactly what the problem is so this is
actually a really really cool really
well done action so you can opt into
using that you can also write your own
so we've got this tool kit that will
help you create your own action so all
you have to do is clone this repository
to get started and then you just go and
write some write some code really easily
and that will let you I don't know
deploy to your own infrastructure it
will help you run your own linting tools
whatever you want to
and share with the community or with
your New York organization you can do by
building an action let me give you a
more concrete example of that
so one of my other co-workers has built
an action that will run all every time
an issue is commented on in a repository
how many people have played untitled
goose game a couple of y'all okay for
the ones that haven't a go do it go get
it if you don't own a switch go buy one
and then buy untitled goose game it
really is great it sounds ridiculous I
know so you play a goose you are a goose
and you are in a town it's a town it's a
lovely town and it's full of lovely
people they're just trying to go about
their day and ure goose and you sneak up
behind them and you know like honk to
Surprise them and oh it sounds
ridiculous but it is quite fun and so
one of my co-workers has created an
action that brings that to github so
what I'm going to do is out of comments
to an issue and if we go and look at my
workflow I have a workflow that runs
every time an issue comment is created
so anytime somebody comments on any
issue this workflow will run and it will
use his action it's called hawk action
and what happens when his workflow when
his action runs if I open up this issue
that I created and then commented on my
comments is now gone and it's replaced
by an angry goose so what his action
actually does is anytime you say
anything except or that doesn't have
honk in it your issue is removed and
replaced with an angry goose so it
terrorizes your github repository now
obviously there is absolutely no use for
this however it does sort of show the
things that you can do with github
actions so you're able to
to respond to any activity on github and
then use our REST API to basically
perform any activity in response so
although you know I've shown you a lot
of continuous integration we're close
deployment we're closed and integrations
with other github services I hope this
gives you an idea that it really is just
an open-ended platform that you can use
and you can extend github with so I'm
afraid I am out of time however I'm
happy to hang around and take your
questions if you are shy or if you are
in a hurry totally understandable if you
have questions I'm still happy to answer
them the best way to reach me is Twitter
I'm at Thompson that's Thomson without a
P so ETH om s o N and I am happy to talk
to you about github actions or I guess
github or get in general so thanks so
much I hope you enjoy the rest of the
conference
[Applause]